are you a wrestling guy all the jokes
that we do about wrestling do you watch
it
oh this the truth is man if i had to be
real honest there was a guy in our
i don't want to say our neighborhood but
in our probably an adjacent neighborhood
that trained
wrestlers when i was growing up really
yeah and did you get trained huh no but
i'd go watch
you go check it out i'd try to get in
there and i got the britches one time
for uh
you know chris christopher yeah and it
was they got me some shitty ones you
know all they had they got me in one
with the ballet surplus or whatever so
i'm wearing some [ __ ]
little billy elliot's out there
hand-me-downs oh yeah yeah
i look like a damn newsie you know i
look like a news
selling papers and watching training i
look like a newsy at the gym you know
but i'd go over there and watch them you
know and the guy had a ring set up in
his own yard you know when they'd throw
him off the ropes and do the body slam
you know
love that and they had a uh this one
wrestler guy who was
i don't say mentally disabled probably
had autism before they had autism so it
was like oh that guy's a [ __ ] you
know
strong yeah and it would be like this
guy fireboy was his uh
wrestling thing you know and he had like
uh the pants yeah with the flames on the
side
and some kind of doc martens but before
doc martens you know nurse martins you
know
this guy had like these lace-up boots
and he wrote fireboy on each one you
know
and i'd go over there and watch him
train the guy are you sure
huh are you sure it wasn't andrew uh
yeah it could have been
was it me fireboy what if it would have
been but dude i'll tell you i'll say
this and i'll say this again
man i i still don't understand why some
of the podcast people do not make
a wrestling script
with this i know when you talk about
this i don't have any wrestling in my
blood though
who cares yeah but i don't i don't even
enjoy it it's not for me
then you can still do it have you seen
wrestling dude i know but there's
something about wrestling characters
i don't like time you've ever been angry
at a costume party yeah
that's wrestling bro i know i mean i no
i have i got no fight with a guy at a
costume party
that's wrestling dude it's just the
halloween yeah but we really fought
yeah oh that's good we really fine
then that's not right we really got no
fistfight no i don't like i don't like
um
i never i nev when i was a kid i thought
hulk hogan was cool
and i thought some of the wrestlers were
cool but i never followed it
because something didn't click with me i
didn't like
i don't think i like the boots and the
pants i don't like
i didn't like tight pants on men and
boots yeah
i don't know yeah like well they're in
jeans i guess i could do it if they were
all wearing jeans
and this guy he's his whole thing is
like apathy he doesn't take his hands
out of his pocket he kind of hates the
whole thing that could be you
that's me i'm just happy i'm just yeah
apathetic
apathetic andrew tommy dreamer well see
that's my thing you know i know they
actually slap him too
carl lentz the pastor yeah
i don't yeah i just it's not for me yeah
this is getting weird
it's not for me good evening good
afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah